on redescend
euh fraude faux arrêt de travail
escroquerie on va parler de la carrière
de Bernard
Montier il y av un numéro
spécial c'est dans Capital sur les
fraudes les fruxes arrêts de travail les
escroqueries en tout genre les
journalistes de capital ont enquêté sur
les faux arrêts de travail ils ont pu
constater qu'aujourd'hui on pouvait se
procurer des faux arrêts de maladie pour
moins de 30 € regardez il suffit
aujourd'hui de d'ouvrir réseau social
pour voir à quel point il est facile de
se procurer un arrêt maladie je vous
recommande un article du Parisien récent
comment en 10 minutes pour 10 € j'ai eu
un arrêt maladie sur snapchat nous avons
fait l'essai 30 secondes nous ont suffit
pour recevoir une proposition d'arrêt de
travail à 30 € tarif à
négocier cette profusion d'arnaque c'est
une des raisons qui explique qu'en
disant le nombre d'arrêts de travail
abondi de 30 % pour atteindre l'an passé
un record 8,8 millions alors eh c'est
oui qu'est-ce qu'il y a mais moi ça me
désespère on le dit à chaque fois mais
quand VO démarrer le lundi comme ça
quand vous voyez il est déjà rasser Ilam
Palomba qui va venir attends un peu le
montant des fraudes 16 millions et demi
par jour de fraude à la sécurité sociale
6 milliards par an 6 milliards par an
mais c'est incroyable et et quand on
voit effectivement ce monsieur qui est
derrière qui a déjà fait une frautete
comme ça dites la vérité non ah
non non pas moi non pas vous bah moi
j'ai jamais été salarié déjà ah oui
c'est compliqué fraude à la SC quand
même mal d'êre
malade en 6e en 6e j'ai fait un bail
mais un vrai débile mon père est médecin
et donc j'avais pris un certificat
médical j'avais volé un certificat
médical j'ai marqué j'ai fait moi-même
le certificat avec mon écriture de part
bébé frère et j'ai amené le certificat
pour dire que j'étais malade je
soussignis certifie que Cyr est en
mauvais état aujourd'hui
frère j'appelle j'appelle un pote my qui
est toujours mon pote d'ailleurs je lu
dis vas-y viens à la maison ramène le
certificat vas-y et qu'est-ce que j'ai
fait pendant que il y avait il y avait
le collège et en fait juste en bas du
collège il y avait un terrain de foot et
donc je lui envoyé donner le le le le
bail et en fait jeis Allis jouer au foot
just en bas donc la meuf elle fait
comass il donne le bail elle voit
l'écriture de par commass après elle va
vers la
fenêtre
10 minutes après j'avais mon daron qui é
arrivé sur le terrain de foot qui m'a
mis une cl à mon
frère tu connais le allez monte dans la
voiture
[Applaudissements]
dép dépêche-toi je vais tquinter
dépêche-toi je vais desquinter ce je
vais desquinter tu connais quand ta mère
elle te dit attends tu vas voir quand
ton père va rentrer ah ouis combien de
fois ma mère elle m'a dit tu vas voir
elle l'appelle il est là non il est là
il est là ne le tape pas dislui et
écoute je vais rentrer je vais
lesquinter je vais
lesquinter et vous craignez plus votre
papa ou votre maman MAM CR personne en
fait problème non franchement crois que
même petit il C person non mais non non
mais je je discutais ça va oh peut
discuter quand même oh 2 minutes vous
disiez ça à vos parents et on peut
discuter 2 minutes minutes ça va on peut
discuter vous avez dû les rendre dingue
non mais parce qu'il y il est venu avec
le faux certificat alors'est c'était
quoi la punition du coup la punition
ouais bah la punition c'est que je te
vis aller à
l'école tout simplement euh il y a le
même problème avec les faux comptes CAF
vous avez vu ça ou pasou vous avez vu ça
ça va toi tu tu s bien dans
l'émission non mais je vois que vous
occuper des vieux pour leur trouver du
travail donc peut-être allez
allez en gros moi j'ai une technique
pour créer des C CAF au nom des gens et
toi tu touche à sur RSA tous les mois du
coup cela semble un peu gros alors nous
tentons l'expérience après un règlement
de 80 € en Bitcoin le frudur nous envoie
un mail avec tout ce qu'il faut pour
accéder à un compte CAF mais ce compte
RSA estil vraiment actif pour le
vérifier nous appelons la CAF avec les
identifiants de suite pour
puiss quelques semaines plus tard en
effet voici la somme qui arrive sur
notre compte en banque 2421,79
soit un paiement de 4 mois de ça à peine
croyable la faille est bien réelle
taz-vous c'est moi qui lu ai donné
l'adresse c'est bon euh Géraldine bravo
pour tout ce que tu as fait ce
weekend donc vous avez vu ça c'est
scandaleux 165 en fait dès que je me
tourne vers quelqu'un dit c'est
scandaleux vousz Ren non 165 millions on
détourné chaque jour quand même le RSA
c'est pour tout le monde c'est notre
sécurité sociale à nous tous c'est du
vol c'est dégueulasse vous tapez sur le
net et vous obtenez ça là il y a un vrai
problème qu'il faut régler évidemment en
plus ce monsieur s'est vanté à la
télévision il est passé il a montré sa
tête et tout il devrait aller en to
direct mais en fait l'assurance maladie
et l'Ordre des médecins ils essayent de
faire fermer son site et il n'y arrive
pas il n'y arrive pas son
siteess de
son c'est surtout qu'on on pensait avec
les sorts du numérique on réussirait à
mieux combattre tous ces phénomènes et
en fait c'est de pire en pire c'est que
tous ceux qui je sens que tu es pas
convaincu par ce que je dis si mais j'en
ai rien à taper non non non j'adore non
vous mieux combattre avec le numérique
ouais mais là je sais pas mais en fait
c'est le contraire qui se
passe même lui il
devient il est arrivé il était bien vous
savez qu'on attendait de savoir quand
est-ce que tu oui on l' déjà dit la
semaine dernière bien plutôt que prévu
non mais e tout me en fait en fait à
chaque fois dans les pronostics on est
pas bon parce qu'à chaque fois les mecs
vent beaucoup plus
incroyable il y a aussi des médecins qui
arnaque ça je déteste ça he pas mon père
qui ferait ça je vous le dis je le
connais c'est notamment le cas de
certains dentistes qui gonfl leur
facture d'ailleurs petite info je vais
chez le dentiste le 27
novembreé à la base je suis venu pour
faire un simple détartrage il est
bénéficiaire de la CMU alors pour son
détartrage comme pour les principaux
soins médicaux il n'a pas à payer les
factures sont directement adresser à la
sécurité sociale il m'ont facturé cor d
d'autres prations so dent en plus de son
détartrage le cabinet a donc ajouté des
actes fictifs 1800 € facturé en janvier
2022 puis
4479 un mois plus tard pour un total de
plus de 6000
€ sans doute le détartrage le plus cher
du monde c'est dégueulasse
ça c'est monie courante par contre parce
que par la semaine dernière j'ai mon
petit frère qui est jeune je pense pas
qu'il avait besoin de ça on lui a
proposé un détartrage à 900 € quoi et
ouais et en fait ça c'est ça arrive tous
les jours ce genre de pratique mon
dentiste il est incroyableas
gratuit c'est
bien grat
grat
pour on se recommande de
vousend va la fraise dans la
gueule P ou pas p vous alliez chez lui
non mais non je lui dis non ça
va va est-ce que vous lui faites de la
promo sur insta non pas du tout pas du
tout c'est vra même pas non je fais
jamais de promo pour personne il fait
pas mal ça fait pas mal mais les mecs le
dentiste alors Mo j'adore le dentiste je
crois franchement quand je vais chez le
dentiste je préfère non mais je préfère
aller manger une semaine chez gilberdez
non mais sans charier c'est truc de tu
sors et tu sais tu sors et tu as
l'impression que tu sais tu en fait
toute ta tête ta té elle elle est
fatiguée
on dirait frère on dirait que tu as
vraiment fait un truc de ouf tu vas chez
le dentiste toi oui j'ai un ami
maintenant
dentiste ouis c'est mon ami il s'appelle
Gilles maintenant parce que j'ai des
problèmes c'est que je peux pas ouvrir
la bouche donc du coup ouais ouais c'est
par c'est coincé donc bah depuis mon
accident à Furiani tout est coincé en
fait j'ai l'air comme ça bien portant
mais tout va mal et donc en fait lui il
m'a compris non l' non
plus com voilà non mais c'est vrai tuar
pas tu as du mal donc tu peux pas faire
genre non non on fait en si fois en fait
quoi en si fois quand on soigne par
exemple une carie j'y vais six fois on
fait si fois ou tu peux ouvir la bouche
comme ça je peux tenir 6 8 minutes pas
plus
hor ou ouais ou ouais mais c'est pas
facile ce que je vis enfin
voilà c'est ouf je peux y aller avec
vous chez le dentiste par que moi la
semaine dernière j'ai mangé un sandwich
au poulet et je dis au mec il y a des
caillou dans ton sandwich tu étais relou
fais attention ma et j'ai cassé ma dent
en mangeant de sandwich j'étais en train
de bouffer ma dent dis-moi toi en fait
c'est un jour
UNEC à Noël à
[Applaudissements]
noëlère il y a pas un jour où il perd
pas d c'est un truc de ouf
frère derrière lui il y a des dents
c'est ah ben il y a Ron qui est venu tu
vois un colier non mais fatigué je pense
il y a de plus en plus de vol aussi en
pharmacie pas si vous avez vu ça les
voleurs ont une technique très très bien
rodée qui a déjà volé quelque chose dit
maintenant Pharm Mo j'avou un truc tout
à l'heure vous avez volé un truc j'ai
volé l'orange du marchand non non non
j'ai déjà volé un truc moi ouais non
mais il y a
longtemps bil total je vous expliquerai
mais bon c'est pas pas ouf non plus pas
ouf non plus pour proposer leur dernière
nouveauté ils ont ce sa vert comme font
les
voleurs donc le principe il est très
simple vous prenez
l'aluminium vous plaquez cet aluminium
dans le sac seule couche ça suffit pour
si vous êtes un vrai voleur vous savez
qu'il faut mettre
cououche il vont être capable
effectivement de passer à travers les
porti même rempli avec des produits B
d'tivol
ça fait peur j'ai du mal à y croire au
passage des portiques il ne se passe
rien ah voilà tu un petit message d'un
de mes meilleurs amis Aurélien qui
m'écrit qui é avec moi donc hier soir
Joko c'est pas le meilleur joueur de
tennis c'est le meilleur sportif de
l'histoire il comprend rien une fois
encore le Gill ver mercici bravo bravo
Aurel et je suis complètement d'accord
avec lui c'est le plus grand sportif de
tous les temps mais non arrêtez
chux j'aime beaucoup votre ami mais
c'est pas sérieux tu connais pas mon
ami Jord mercredi voir mer on en
discutera j'espère on en
discutera on en discuter
connard oh quoi'est Mohamed
Ali qu'est-ce tu compares mais vous êtes
fou quoi jokovi vous avez V tout ce
qu'il a gagné c'est le plus grand
sportif de tous les temps mais quel
PEL sportif magnifi quel PEL quel PEL
quel
pelokov c'est le plus grand sportif de
tous les temps sois pas énervé je dis
c'est compliqué j'ai hâte d'avoir votre
ami en face de
moi coup de pression mais parce qu'il
est
je un ticac il nous regarde il vient
tout de suiteoulez les gars Aurélien
Bastien tout ça on mange tous ensemble
ce soir non sans rigoler venezz me
rejoindre au studio on mange ensemble
après voilà donc c'est bon vous avez
peur de les faire venir là donc vous
allez dîner avec eux j'ai bien compris
mais il venir ici on va voir on va mer
allez vas-y ah